One of the better-known breaches,
cyber attacks,
that occurred towards the end of
2013 was the Target store breach.
So in this case,
you would want to ask this question,
what is of value that
somebody was after?
And if somebody was after, who was that?
What is the threat source?
Then we can say, well,
what vulnerability did they exploit?
So the Target case, essentially what
they were after was credit card
data that is there on the point-of-sale
systems that are in Target stores.
The people who are after
it are cyber criminals
because they want to profit
from the stolen information.
And the vulnerability they
exploited is an interesting one.
So, Target stores had
an HVAC contractor.
The hack actually began with a phishing
message to an employee
of that HVAC company.
Through that phishing attacks, they
were able to get credentials that gave
the cyber criminals access
to Target's network.
And once they were on Target's networks,
then they were able to get to
the point-of-sales systems where they
installed malware to siphon
off the credit card numbers.
So this is a real-world example
where the security mindset,
essentially we are saying,
where does the threat come from?
Cyber criminals.
What are they after?
Credit card data.
What vulnerability was there in
the system that was exploited?
Well, we just talked about it.